[Musique]
donc nous sommes à Pickering Beach
Delaware et
c'est en fait l'une des
plages de frai les plus productives au monde,
les gens les appellent des fossiles vivants
pour cette raison particulière, je veux dire qu'il y
a un certain nombre d'espèces très anciennes
qui ont vécu pendant  longtemps mais c'est
certainement celui que l'on peut
approcher
[Musique]
limules
à la différence de leur nom commun
ce ne sont pas des crabes c'est en fait
nos triples qui sont liés aux
araignées et aux scorpions
donc ils viennent au printemps quand le
l'eau commence à
se réchauffer et ensuite ils arrivent dans les
nouvelles et pleines lunes de mai et juin
de choses, mais nous avons maintenant
une toute nouvelle vague de vaccins
produits et développés pour
la lutte contre le covid et ils
sont testés
sur le même test fabriqué à partir du sang de crabe en fer à cheval
[Musique]
crois que nous avons tourné le coin et je
pense que notre population va bien s'en sortir, en
particulier avec l'introduction de
tests d'endotoxines alternatifs qui
vont vous soulager encore plus
[Musique]